a road trip from seattle to vancouver
takes about three hours
there's pretty scenery to look at along
the way
and a really exciting border to cross
once you make it into british columbia
everything changes in an instant
it's like entering another world
in vancouver most public servants are
required to drive teslas
so you see the things just about
everywhere
all of the clocks here run on steam and
play songs
[Music]
and the airports
are in the water
[Music]
oddities like these aside it would be
hard to dream up a more beautiful city
beautiful mountains
beautiful buildings
beautiful geese
beautiful graffiti complemented by
beautiful filthy alleyways
[Music]
and if you know the right spots you can
eat like a king in vancouver
this counts as a light lunch in
chinatown
and if you know the right guy
at the right hole in the wall
you can get what you need it's pure
but i'm in vancouver for more than just
mainlining maple syrup
there are people who would say that
building a super lifelike extremely
intelligent robot is a terrible idea
the kind of thing that could lead to the
downfall of the human species
but today i will visit a startup called
sanctuary ai
they've built this crazy robot that has
artificial intelligence baked into it
and it also has these very lifelike
hands
sanctuary claims to have the smartest
most capable android on the planet
the only thing we can say for certain is
that because the robot is being built in
canada it will be ridiculously polite
i'm sorry
excuse me
my bad
[Music]
sanctuary ai was started by a handful of
engineers in 2019
the company's ceo is this fella
and it's chief technology officer is
suzanne gildert
if suzanne looks familiar to some of you
that's because she's been on hello world
before
her previous company was called kindred
and it made robotic arms that could pick
and place items in factories
suzanne's new company is a lot like her
old company
only better
do you want to shake hands yeah
absolutely
nice to meet you nice to meet you
[Laughter]
so
this is our general purpose robot it's a
humanoid in form and function it's
designed to be good at doing work tasks
do i call it an it's what should we how
do we refer i usually refer to the robot
as eric
eric is our pilot who you'll see taking
control of the robot he will be our
operator today hi eric
i think people have seen robots at a car
factory but like walk us through some of
the
advances you guys have made you know
versus that type of machine
most robots that you'll find in industry
are special purpose
and they're programmed in a very
different way they're programmed to do a
repetitive task over and over again so
that robot it doesn't really know where
things are it's just executing some
pre-written routines so what we're
trying to do here is build a robot that
is actually aware of its surroundings
it's building up a mental model of
everything it's seeing in real time and
is therefore able to do different tasks
more general purpose tasks and then a
big part of that would be the dexterity
of the hands i know that yeah you guys
have been
focusing on that for quite some time
yeah these are sort of about the fourth
generation hands that we built so maybe
eric you can hold out your hand i can
show some of the features
so obviously a human-like hand for
fingers and the thumb
these things you see here are sensors
that gives the robot a sensor haptic
sense of touch
when these pressure sensors are
pressed the data signals go into the
software system they're also relayed to
the pilot so eric has like a glove on
yeah and he can feel yes eric you could
feel that when you're poked uh yeah
why don't we play game of chess and we
can talk through some of the components
while we do that
all right so you're white you go first
right uh yeah sounds good
should have uh pre-planned my move
i will be using the sicilian defense
just i'll let you know seems i might be
outmatched
eric when you're doing this i mean are
you just seeing the piece like i am or
there's um some sort of guide like do
you have a helmet on yes i do i have a
vr headset so what i'm seeing is uh
stereo vision through the camera you're
looking at yeah you can almost see
behind you right uh yeah
oh i didn't even see that camera over
here
i think that probably if people saw this
for the first time and then they hear
that there's a human operator behind it
they would kind of be like oh well
that's not
i wanted you know the full
robot so a lot a lot of people ask well
you know isn't isn't this just a person
behind the scenes
but having a person behind the scenes
allows us to gather lots of very
human-like training data to train the
software system train the ai algorithms
to be more human-like over time
so we're currently just using vr rigs
off the shelf gear but we're planning on
having some new rigs made that actually
give force feedback to the pilot as well
so eric can you hold your arm out and
i did this the pilot would actually be
able to feel the force feedback as well
these robots are designed to work
alongside people so we need them to be
very safe and one of the things about
this robot and its motor system is it
actually operates in a force controlled
mode so what that means is the robot
will try and hold at the position of the
arm but if a maximum force is applied
that is greater than a certain force it
will give
tell tell me a little bit
about your background just because i
know you you've been into
electronics and computing since you were
a kid right well i've loved electronics
and robotics and things like that since
i was little
i did a degree in physics and a phd in
physics and electronics too
and then from there i worked in the
quantum computing space for a while and
eventually found my way into ai
you grew up in the uk yeah that's right
i know like outside of this you have all
these interesting
tech related pursuits yeah so i have
quite a lot of interesting hobbies that
i do i do like to do paintings
they've kind of moved towards a more
tech electronics theme and they're
actually inspired a lot by computer
history so a lot of the paintings you'll
see are things like close-ups of old
microprocessors
there are even a few that are like robot
power circuits
so always thinking about robots
whose move is it eric i believe it's
your turn i'm not going to lose to a
ai human
team
human okay i'm okay with that strategy
chess is a really interesting game for
several reasons
one is it's fairly easy now for software
systems to solve the intellectual part
of chess so it's been historically used
in ai many many many times for teaching
machines what we're really trying to
show here though is that it's the parts
of chess that people find easy
like picking up a piece moving it
knowing where all the pieces are on the
board those are the parts that people
find very easy computer algorithms find
that part extremely hard
but also chess is a stand-in for all
different kinds of activities that you
might have to do in the world of work
maybe things need organizing in the
right locations
you need to take stock of items in a
retail store or you can imagine instead
of chess pieces these were small parts
on an assembly or a citation line
i mean the goal is
eventually then the robot is just
smart enough it's just doing its own
thing with no human operator in some job
yeah for certain tasks so i'd like to
see this um robot system be able to
automate the really mundane boring parts
of the uh
sorry i gotta readjust something
i would appreciate if you gave me a
minute or two i'll just let him adjust
that and move out of the way
[Music]
so i'd like to see these robots doing
the sort of boring mundane parts of
tasks and then the pilots are now freed
up to be more like the overseers are the
managers of a group of robots so you can
imagine a group of robots all being
controlled by a single pilot almost like
the person becomes more of a manager um
and the robots become more like the
manual workers okay
so about 95 of all jobs the dexterity of
fingers precludes conventional robotic
systems from doing them
so we have attempted to build uh the
world's best robotic hands
because hands are really important for
work
so we are working on integrating
state-of-the-art robots specifically for
manipulation of the world through hands
with a new kind of ai system that
integrates a lot of the tools that
people have been developing around the
world into a platform that's intended to
give these robots the kind of
understanding of the world that is kind
of a baseline for work
it's interesting because i think there's
definitely people who'd look at what you
guys are making they're like oh great
now you're going to take all these
factory jobs from people well it's not
it's not taking jobs in fact i think
that it's starting to be recognized that
the problem that we face in terms of the
employment labor market is actually the
opposite problem there aren't enough
people
to do the kinds of work that needs to
get done to support
the continued flourishing of
civilization our way of life
there are more than 11 million unfilled
positions in the us right now
the world needs more workers especially
in the kinds of jobs that people
typically don't want to do those 11
million open jobs right now those are
the kinds of things that we're going to
target and that's a big number and 11
million jobs it's only going to grow
over time birth rates are plummeting and
11 million robots of our sort in the
world doing those jobs doesn't take a
single job away from anyone but 11
million robots out in the world is an
enormous business it's starting to
become at the scale of the automotive
industry and i i do believe that this
is the birth of a new industry it's it
it sort of looks like robotics and it
sort of looks like ai but it's a new
thing
and it's going to rival the biggest
industries there are today in importance
and scale when it gets going
[Music]
okay so you're moving in on me quick
distracting me with your fancy hands
i'm going to deal with your night
because it's really bothering me
ah my knights yeah
he's a troublemaker yeah
what did you get up to this weekend uh
you know just robot stuff
a lot of chess
i was practicing for uh for you
i know you're pretty good
[Music]
oh i don't like that
i will take this
put it over here
not cool
not cool
[Music]
oh yeah
you don't miss a beat man
all right i will i will concede i can
see
you've got me beat
very good game well played thank you sir
thank you
so we saw
eric as the pilot picking up the chess
pieces quite easily
using his human mind
and here the robot is trying to learn
what it means to actually pick up a
chess piece in the same way that a human
would and it does it by trying over and
over and over again
so on this screen over here you can see
a close-up of it trying to grab a chess
piece and you'll see it sort of fumbles
around a little bit at the start but
after enough training episodes it will
learn to grab it in a very human-like
way there's not obviously ten thousand
robot arms do this is all simulated yeah
so here we can have thousands or
hundreds of thousands of hands trying to
pick things up faster than real time so
you're accelerating the learning rate by
millions of times so the physics engine
the rules that have been put into the
software to mimic
like gravity and the the different
properties of our world are good enough
that this is actually training the hand
yeah they're they're getting there
so uh if you think about
where you could have done this many like
a few years ago you might think well i
could use a game engine maybe because
game engines are pretty good simulated
worlds but then when you get deep into
game engines you find they're sort of
optimized to make games look good they
have a lot of animations in them they
don't have a lot of real physics so
we're actually bootstrapping on game
engine technology but they're in our
systems going beyond that and trying to
mimic physics very well and so even
something like the interaction of the
end of a fingertip with an object has to
be modeled very well so you need a
really good physics engine
[Music]
what do we have here yeah so we saw the
grasping algorithm being trained what
we're actually seeing here are those
grasps being realized
it's taking what it's learned and
putting it into practice
so it's it's motion planning not just
the grasp anymore but that in
combination with the entire movement of
the robot body
your eyes kind of lit up when you're
talking about about this why yeah so
when you just look at this from the
outside it's like oh a virtual robot is
moving a chess piece so what but to me
this is like a spark of life moment
because what you're actually seeing is
fully autonomous grasping and
manipulation of an object in a scene
where none of this is pre-programmed or
specified it's figuring out where those
pieces are just by looking at the scene
looking at them you can see in this view
it's actually trying different potential
grasps and then it's actually executing
the move using real physics
okay you've got this virtual robot
getting more sophisticated in doing
these things but like in my head i feel
like the second you
have the real robot there's gonna be all
these differences in the chest piece and
the physics between the hand and the
pieces there are still some
discrepancies between reality and the
simulation but that gap is closing all
the time and to me this could transfer
and generalize to other types of objects
other scenarios
so rather than just thinking about a
chess game think about cutlery being
laid out in a restaurant or something
like that
so what we're seeing now is we're seeing
a little bit of a peak inside the the ai
mind when it's running okay so if you
remember earlier we saw the vr type of
piloting imagine now instead of having
to control the robot with all this vr
gear you just have a drop down list of
options
so you can see
there are two screens here
this one we call the outer world model
so this is a digital twin of reality
this is a simulation of the world and
it's a simulated robot
this one down here is the robot's mental
model of the world
so this is inside its mind and this is
outside its mind
so you'll see the main difference
between these two at the moment it's
pretty obvious there is a chess board
with the pieces here and it's not here
so the reason is that the robot is not
looking at the chess board
and it's never seen it before so it
doesn't have a mental model of the
chessboard but say i'm now
a pilot here i can use the command
look down here
we're now controlling the simulated
robot look down and now you can see the
chessboard appeared here so now this is
it's building up this inner mental
picture of what's going on in real time
yeah what's good they're all like moving
around so they're jostling around a
little bit and the reason is is that
these are all being detected and figured
out what they are in real time
so okay so this is super interesting
what happened
down here
a bunch of the pieces have disappeared
it's like blocking its vision yeah so
see the hand is in front of the pieces i
think it's like a six-month-old baby
if you show it something and then you
hide it like peek-a-boo thinks it's gone
so that's a very human-like trade to the
developing minds to go through this
stage where if you can't see it doesn't
exist so what we really want to get to
here is that this robot in any real
world scenario would roll into a room it
would look around and it would start
building a mental model of everything it
was seeing in real time including the
room and all the objects and what they
are and where they're located
it's funny because in some ways i'm
picturing my head like 1960s sci-fi like
a android that is moving around and what
you guys are making is still sort of in
some ways people's first conception of
where all this was was heading well i
think so yeah and i i like to think of
sanctuary's mission as going back to the
sort of original vision of ai when
people like alan turing and marvin
minsky and these people were thinking
about how do we actually make a machine
or a system that that thinks and behaves
like like a person
if we want systems to be able to work in
the same way people do interact with us
in the same way people do they need a
human-like body and a very human-like
intelligence
and you think the dystopian stuff is all
you're optimistic by nature or you think
it's all
overblown and
if we manage to develop fully autonomous
ai in a general purpose robot you might
ask what will that look like will you
know how how will it change the world
what's going to be going on
but you saw it earlier right it'll look
exactly like it did when eric was
piloting it's just there won't be a
person in a vr suit in there so i would
ask you well was that scary and
terrifying dystopian
right
and i also think if you are focusing on
a very optimistic future where you have
robots working alongside people helping
people i think you will make that future
come to pass
yet people accusing you of being naively
optimistic but i think you need that if
you want to make that future real
and if you're really optimistic about it
it's more likely to happen
i promise i'm smiling behind the camera
do robots say cheese yeah absolutely all
right one two three
cheese cheese
[Music]
you